hola
[Música]
[Aplausos]
no no
[Música]
conexión
todos buscamos una conexión todos
queremos encontrar una conexión pero no
estoy segura de que entendamos que es
una conexión no sabemos cómo definirlo
cuando pregunte una persona me dijo que
era una relación otra persona me dijo
que la comunicación y por último me
dijeron que era una unión
qué es una conexión
yo creo que todos tenemos un concepto
muy diferente a lo que puede llegar a
significar conexión
y para mí
una conexión no es un que sino que
contiene
para mi conexión es ella
ahora ella es mi hermana gemela les
pongo esta otra foto para porque creo
que la foto anterior es un poquito vieja
y creo que tenían que tener una foto un
poquito más actual pero también la pongo
para todas esas personas que de verdad
cuando me subí pensaron ella ya pasó no
sorpresa soy su clon
y droga no es de una gemela pero no me
digan que no hay personas así porque ya
van alrededor de seis personas que me
felicitan por una charla que aún no he
dado
pero hoy han cumplido su cumplida
entonces mi manilla siempre estamos
juntas siempre estamos juntas y entonces
siempre que conocemos gente lo primero
que nos dicen por ley es
se ven igualitas y yo como jurado no
llevamos escuchando los 15 años 16 años
pero bueno también siempre nos preguntan
si estamos conectadas y si podemos
hablar telepáticamente nosotras siempre
decimos que sí
ahora entiendo ahora entiendo que de
verdad no solo estamos conectados ante
nosotras sino también a los demás
un ser humano está hecho de 430 millones
de conexiones neuronales a lo largo de
su vida busca hacer conexiones tanto
sentimentales como conexiones físicas
con la gente que lo rodea nosotros
estamos hechos a base de conexiones por
otro lado el mundo en el que vivimos
también está hecho a base de conexiones
entiendo que es difícil de creer que el
mundo tan grande con 510 millones de
kilómetros de superficie terrestre
conoce 8.7 millones de especies y con
más de 7500 millones de humanos es
difícil de creer que una sola persona
significa cambio total
ahora cada acción cuenta porque todos
estamos conectados ante nosotros sus
pensamientos y mis acciones nos afectan
a todos ya cada una de las personas que
están aquí no me creen tenemos un
ejemplo muy claro el hecho de que yo
haya empezado a luchar la santa genes
asia en estos diez segundos que dejé
pasar que me tomé el tiempo de verlos de
observar los pique que yo haya estado
sentada tuvo una reacción diferente en
todos pero tuvo una reacción y hoy ven
las caras preocupadas porque crean que
se me olvidó lo que les voy a decir y
unas caras que creyeron que era mi
hermana muy confundidas y unas caras
medio tensas porque querían que esté un
concurso de no parpadear
y otras casas que de verdad querían
escuchar lo que lo que yo quiero decir
ahora el hecho de que yo haya empezado a
sentar en esa silla hace que su visión
de mi charla sea completamente diferente
a la que hubiera sido si yo hubiera
empezado para que yo haya empezado
sentada en esa silla puede cambiar el
mundo entero
porque las personas que están aquí van a
contar lo que vieron hoy lo que pasó hoy
y otras personas se lo van a contar
alguien lo hace si sucesivamente cada
acción cuenta
a lo largo de la historia ha habido
muchas mentes que ya se habían planteado
un mundo unido un mundo integral
hegel por ejemplo decía que la realidad
no es una suma de sus partes sino que se
entera que lo importante no sólo no es
la realidad en sí y los elementos que la
conforman siguen las relaciones de
interacciones que éstos tienen entre
ellos
alexander von humboldt una vez dijo en
esta gran cadena de causas y efectos no
puede estudiar sin ningún hecho
aisladamente en su libro cosmos él
plantea esta posibilidad de un mundo
integral de un mundo unido
en la red de la vida de humboldt todos y
cada uno de los seres vivos afectamos a
los demás de manera directa y de manera
indefinida
todos estamos conectados según humboldt
eso significa que tanto las plantas como
los animales como los humanos afectamos
este mundo en este mundo que nos rodea
pero los humanos tenemos una ventaja y
es que pensamos nosotros somos
conscientes de este mundo que nos rodea
nosotros sabemos de dónde venimos y
adónde queremos ir pero a veces no lo
parece la verdad es que los humanos nos
tomamos nuestro pensamiento a la ligera
una persona a la vez dijo cuida tus
pensamientos porque se conviertan en
palabras tus palabras en acciones sus
acciones se conviertan en tus hábitos y
tus hábitos son lo que define a tu
realidad
nuestra mente condiciona nuestras vidas
no sólo influyen cómo nos sentimos sino
también cómo actuamos
eso significa entonces que pensar de
manera positiva es lo mejor que podrías
hacer por ti mismo porque el ser humano
piensa todo el tiempo
pero que les tengo una noticia pensar
positivo no solo te sirve a ti sino a
todos los que estamos aquí un
pensamiento positivo si aumenta la
autoconfianza pero también aumenta este
sentimiento de responsabilidad no sólo
hacia ti mismo si nuestras necesidades y
hacia el mundo en el que vivimos
entonces imagínense un mundo en el que
las personas nos diéramos cuenta de lo
importante que somos que las personas
nos tomamos el tiempo de observar este
mundo al que vivimos de analizarlo
que nos diéramos cuenta de la fragilidad
que tiene porque depende de todos y de
cada uno de nosotros imagínense un mundo
en el que nuestros pensamientos
desencadenan movimientos de conciencia o
que se ganará movimientos de amor
piensen en un planeta tierra desde los
humanos no perdiéramos la paciencia
complete el que tendríamos nuestro valor
yo quiero un planeta tierra en el que la
impotencia no exista que ningún ser
humano siente impotencia porque seamos
honestos cuanto a quien se han sentido
impotentes
o ha sentido que sus pensamientos están
en su contra
o han llegado ese momento en el que sus
pensamientos ni siquiera los dejan
respirar
nuestra mente condiciona nuestras vidas
impotencia para mí es esto
impotencia para mí es saber lo que está
pasando en el mundo es saber que los
animales están sufriendo por lo que los
humanos le hemos logrado hacer al
planeta en el que vivimos todos es tener
que ver las futuras generaciones no
saber lo que es un oso polar porque se
extinguía es tener que vivir en un mundo
que segundo a segundo se cae a pedazos
por lo que le hemos logrado hacer
pero voy a ser honesta no me siento del
todo impotente porque porque tengo mis
pensamientos porque tengo mi mente y mi
mente no es mi arma más no es mi arma
más poderosa no es mía
hay una coach que me gusta mucho de la
película la invención de hugo cabret
dicho por el mismísimo hubo que dice a
las máquinas nunca les sobran partes
siempre tienen las piezas de actas que
necesitan entonces pensé que si el mundo
es un mecanismo
yo no podía ser una pieza extra tiene
que estar aquí por una razón yo
significa que tú también estás aquí por
una razón
así que yo te pido a ti tú que puedes
cambiarlo todo
si quieres tú que defines hacia dónde
vamos y hasta dónde llegamos vive una
vida increíble vive una vida que tú
quieras vivir pero sé consciente lo que
piensas porque tus pensamientos nos
afectan a todos
imagínate que tus pensamientos afectan a
las 250 personas sentadas en esta sala
te pido que dejes tus huellas y
porque siempre quiero que recuerdes que
en este mundo conectado en el que
vivimos
tú haces la diferencia
[Aplausos]